today on the matt welsh show amy coney
barrett's neighbor has some great advice
for the protesters who showed up at her
house we'll talk about that also the
pro-life organization whose office was
burned and defaced now reveals the
hateful messages that leftists have been
leaving since the attack and a
self-professed queer surgeon defends his
practice of chopping the breasts off of
teenage girls plus the plus cps shows up
after parents enter their six-year-old
into a marathon apparently you can't run
a marathon with your six-year-old but
you can change his gender i guess in our
country and in our daily cancellation a
popular twitch streamer nearly burns
down her house live on camera while
trying to cook a steak maybe it's time
they start teaching basic life skills in
school again just a thought we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
matte wall show
[Music]
before we get to the show i just want to
remind you that today is the day folks
tickets are on sale and now is your
chance to join me in the daily wire crew
for backstage live on june 29th at the
historic ryman auditorium in downtown
nashville tennessee come sit listen and
marvel at uh me ben shapiro michael
knowles andrew clavin and daily wire god
king jeremy boring for our biggest live
event of the year
uh tickets are available now so don't
miss out head over to dailywire.com
and get your tickets now before they're
gone i want to have a big uh enormous
representation of the sweet baby getting
there especially so make sure you go and
get those tickets daily wire backstage
live at the ryman in nashville on june
29th
when the pro abortion radicals descended
on justice kavanaugh's house last week
they had the support in fact they were
led by one of kavanaugh's own neighbor
neighbors a woman named lacey wooten
holway who organized a demonstration
against her own neighbor inviting the
militants into her neighborhood and
inflicting them on not just kavanaugh
but the whole community predictably she
was motivated by personal grievance it
turns out she apparently um has an
abortion of her own in her past
certainly no surprise that she's willing
to turn on her neighbor given that she
was willing to kill her own child
loyalty is not her strong suit hallway
also has a non-binary quote unquote 12
year old who uses they them pronouns in
other words
she fulfills every cliche of a
privileged leftist middle-aged white
woman that you can imagine i don't know
this for certain but we can assume that
she also has multiple pets and refers to
herself as a dog mom but the situation
was a bit different when the baby killer
crew made their way this week to amy
coney barrett's house decked out in
their handmaids tail costumes her
neighbors seem to be considerably less
enthused by their presence in fact
one of them spoke out on camera now he
didn't give any impassioned speech or
anything like that he gave no
indications of where he stands
ideologically one way or another instead
he responded as a normal just common
sense kind of guy
and he said something off the cuff that
was quite i think important and profound
and worth reflecting on but first let's
listen
so sir you're a neighbor of uh the
justices or justice amy coney barrett
correct i am and how do you feel about
the protesters coming to your
neighborhood
it's none of their business why are they
here
do you think it's inappropriate for them
to protest in front of the house of
course it is do they have the right to
protest or should they be going through
the right to protest but not in front of
someone's house
they live here this is where she lives
absolutely so would you do you have
anything to say to the protesters
what i just said
they shouldn't be doing this
go home and get a family
what i like about the clip is that the
guy could easily be a democrat for all
we know in fact given the location
there's a high statistical likelihood of
exactly that but he's approaching this
situation with exactly the kind of
casual everyday common sense that's
sorely missing from
our culture at least that common sense
is not often very visible um and then
his statement at the end go home and get
a family
indeed now granted many of these women
have aborted their children and thereby
literally killed their families also
getting a family if you're going to do
it the right way in the best way
requires that you first get a spouse
but the sorts of people who show up at a
pro-abortion rally are not fit to have
spouses in their current state it's hard
for me to recommend that those women go
and get husbands when i certainly would
not recommend that any man go and marry
any of those women
and as much as i advocate for people to
have families the fact is that having a
family will not solve all your problems
and it certainly won't make
automatically make you a better person
it's not going to have the effect
automatically of making you a better
person
um probably won't make you a worse
person but if you're a bad person
already and you remain a bad person once
you have a family
then your badness will suddenly be doing
much more damage
than it did when you were single
so now there will be people subjected to
your badness every day children molded
in an environment infected by it now i
haven't known anyone who became
more selfish when they had kids but i
have known plenty of selfish people who
had kids and remained selfish and now
their selfishness is doing immeasurable
harm on a whole new scale and that an
entirely different level
these are all the caveats to keep in
mind before we endorse the idea that
people should go home and get families
but these are individual caveats
anecdotal concerns
as a general societal prescription it is
certainly the case
that we would be better off culturally
if more people went home and got
families
it's well established that our society
is drifting away from the institution of
the family perhaps you know even
drifting isn't exactly the right word
it's more like we're in a rip current
being pulled furiously out to sea away
from the family people are having fewer
kids
more people are having no kids at all
more are for foregoing marriage entirely
unmarried cohabitation is trending up
marriage is trending down we're all
familiar with a lot of these statistics
the average age of marriage for men now
is 30 years old approaching 31. and for
women it's almost 29. now less than a
century ago it was 24
for men and 21 for women
but
as mentioned
lots of genziers and millennials have no
interest in matrimony at all viewing the
sacrament as old-fashioned out-of-date
oppressive patriarchal etc and so forth
now there's a little bit of a chicken or
egg question here have we slipped into
decadence and collapsed because of our
abandonment of the family or have we
abandoned the family because of the
decadence and collapse i think the
answer is the latter the former and both
at the same time these two things feed
off of each other kind of a mutually
parasitic relationship
how can we solve this by focusing on and
strengthening and reigniting the
institution of the family what advantage
is there in going home and getting
families
well there are many advantages
for one thing your family is an anchor
gives you a fixed point of reference
it gives you a
purpose motivation a reason to work and
sacrifice and endure at the very
beginning of cormac mccarthy's excellent
post-apocalyptic book of the road the
protagonist who's never given his a name
says of his son with whom he's
traversing the desolate wasteland that
was once america he says all i know is
that the child is my warrant and if he
is not the word of god then god never
spoke
it's a little bit obscure but i take
this to mean that the child is his
mission his ward his reason for
persevering his vocation given to him by
god
and that's what you find in your family
if you have the right heart about it
and if you're willing to listen and
understand
to the word of god as he's speaking to
you
your family gives you something to care
about beyond yourself
it gives you a potential
escape hatch from the vicious cycle of
constant shallow self-involvement
again not automatic
you have to be willing to grow in that
kind of way to put in the effort but the
opportunity is there
another thing about family is that it
anchors you not just in the present
but it also gives you a stake in the
future
and this is something that's really
missing from lots of people's lives and
it shows
we don't care a lot about legacy anymore
we don't care about the future we tear
down statues in this country we don't
put them up
but legacy is something that you find in
the family and something you probably
aren't going to find if you sacrifice
family on the altar of professional
achievement which is what people are
told to do these days especially women
after all someone else
after you leave your job
will take the office that you were
sitting in
they'll take the position that you had
you're probably not gonna be missed very
much
the work you did likely will not be
remembered for very long or at all
you'll just be replaced and nothing will
be lost
but nobody can replace a loving and
devoted father or mother
the work you do in your family
in service to your spouse and your
children
rings down the generations
remembered either with fondness or
disdain
and it's there in that vocation where
you can find a happiness that surpasses
whatever fleeting pleasure may be
brought by a pay raise or a bigger house
or a nice vacation
or whatever else you
give your life to if you decide not to
give it to a family
so yes
i think the advice is very good go home
and get a family
not the solution to all of our society's
problems
but it puts us in the right direction
points us towards the answer
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know with everything going on right
now with the news about roe v wade it's
really impossible to avoid the abortion
debate uh which means that you need to
be prepared for it you may think this
means the fight is coming to an end by
the way with roe v wade ending but
abortion legislation returning to the
states means the real battle is just
beginning actually there's no group in
america then better positioned than 40
days for life to help fight this battle
40 days for life has 1 million
volunteers throughout the country
holding peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you may be surprised to hear
that their largest presence is actually
in the country's bluest state
especially california as their biggest
state of all their vigils have closed
many abortion facilities in america and
nearly half of those facilities were in
liberal states where abortions will
continue to remain legal after the fall
of roe from san francisco to chicago to
seattle hardly pro-life areas volunteers
have guided abortion workers to have a
change of heart and quit their jobs just
wonderful and important work they're
doing so as this issue gets out of dc
finally 40 days for life is effectively
changing hearts and minds in the
grassroots of the pro-abortion movement
check out their locations podcasts and
their new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion at 40daysforlife.com
so we heard earlier in the week about
the pro-life organization in wisconsin
that was attacked by a molotov cocktail
and it was uh defaced
and um
and all the rest of it and that by the
way not the only example of this these
these have this has been happening
across the country
by the pro-abortion terrorists well the
website human events has obtained audio
of messages that were left
after this attack and after this this
organization you know they were in the
headlines because of this
and pro-abortion activists have been
calling this place and leaving messages
and they have not been leaving
supportive messages they haven't been
calling to say i'm so sorry this
happened to you we disagree but i you
know i certainly don't think anyone
should have their buildings burned or
molotov cocktails thrown at them that's
not what they're saying um their message
is quite a bit different than that let's
just play this goes on for a while when
i can play the entire thing but just to
get a kind of a taste of it
let's play a little bit of this here it
is
hi i'm calling because i read about the
fire in your building and i'm calling
because i'm curious if it was arson or
rather the good lord showing you an
example of hell and where you belong for
being such a misogynistic
thanks for uh
basically going out there daily and
making sure that women can't have
control over their own bodies and i'm so
thankful that the good lord finally took
action on people like you you're going
to burn as well you're all going to burn
you [ __ ] think you're following the
will of
jesus you're following them and that
will actually you're just evil little
[ __ ] people try to control other
people's lives and next time that voltov
i hope it
doesn't
miss
i hope you all burn with it that's what
you deserve
yeah you must be a pretty perverted
group if that's all you got to do all
day long is think about people's sex
organs
leave your [ __ ] beliefs out of the
government you have no rights to be
fighting into other people's private
family matters
get that out and keep your [ __ ] to
yourself you
idiots
we sick of you and evangelicals pieces
of
go to hell that's where you're going
anyway
yeah i just learned about you ignorant
simplistic waste of scum because of the
fire
and whoever said that fire is a true
american patriot you people are just
utter filth of the planet and it's too
bad your [ __ ] mothers didn't abort each
and every last one of you
hopefully you all get cancer suffer
amounts there are dead before then of
the year
for the betterment of all humanity good
so i think we got the the point there
very very eloquent
very eloquent from those pro-abortion
people uh evangelicals probably my
favorite part of that is the guy who
said
you damn evangelicals
um
and he also he also tells them to keep
their beliefs out of the government
they're not the government this is just
a this is a group this is a private
organization
keep your opinions to yourself well what
they can't say you're not keeping your
opinion to yourself
they're not even allowed to have their
opinions i guess
and keep in mind again that these were
messages that were left
because
this group's building was set on fire
and vandalized and defaced
now just
imagine the shoe on the other foot here
imagine that it was a pro-abortion
organization that was physically
attacked in some way
and then there were a bunch of messages
from pro-lifers saying all that kind of
stuff
now that wouldn't happen and we know
that it wouldn't happen it would never
happen because if it did we'd hear all
about it
but that's just not how pro-lifers don't
that's not how pro-lifers operate
um but this is how they do it it's there
there are a few things about that that
are kind of interesting when i listen to
it the first is how how how often
they make reference to the devil and
kind of religion
now these are
ant anti-god anti-religion you know
secular people
and yet how often do they bring as as in
fact this is a common theme we've talked
about quite a bit over the last couple
of weeks how often do pro-abortion
people
even though on one hand they appear or
claim to hate religion and they always
accuse us of imposing our religion on
others how often do they bring religion
into the conversation religious ideas
religious symbolism religious references
um
very similar you know it very much
reminds me of uh the passage in the
gospels the temptation of christ in the
desert
and his encounter with satan
and what does
satan do he quotes scripture
at jesus
trying to make his own point quoting
scripture of course taking it out of
context just like the left does
uh very much modeling themselves after
their father in hell
but you listen to that you just think
like
how much longer can we actually continue
to live together as one country
when you've got people like this is how
they feel about you
and i wish that i could say that this is
that's just fringe it's it's
rare it's you know
these are the fringe radicals
it's not all that uncommon or all that
rare
every time somebody complains
and it's always somebody on the left
because any other complaint like this
wouldn't get an airing by the mass media
but anytime somebody on the left
is uh you know in the headlines claiming
that they're getting death threats or
whatever
what i always say i always say well
that's that's common we all get death
threats all the time
and it is very common but also
should it be
and what does that say about us as a
country and our in our
potential
the potential of our union going forward
these are these are people like you they
disagree with you and so it's not just
they disagree they want you to die
they're happy when when you are the
victim of violence
they want you to die and burn forever
and hell that's what they want you to
get cancer and die that's how they feel
about you
can we continue to live united
in in in that kind of environment
when you've got two sides really it's
more than two sides because each side is
fractured itself into a bunch of
different pieces but generally speaking
two sides
don't like each other
don't respect each other and worse
it's just you know to even refer to to
say that we're united at all is it's a
it's a joke at this point
it's like some kind of parody of unity
this is not what unity is
well at least we're all united as
americans are we in what way around what
they want us to be dead they want us to
get cancer and die and burn in hell so
that's we're united
it's just it's not sustainable
and at a certain point we gotta we have
to actually start talking about this
there are a few people who will talk
about
like let's get really serious about
the future of our union as a country
does it have a future what does that
look like
we need to seriously start talking about
that because this is just not a
sustainable situation
all right um maisie hirono's uh senator
and like every democrat you know she's
hesitant of course to explain her own
position on abortion and she appeared
this is
somewhat surprising she's on cnn and the
anchor of cnn is actually trying to get
an answer out of her which is pretty
uncommon and you can tell she was taken
aback because got a feel for her a
little bit she's not expecting that
these are her people she's on cnn she's
not expecting they're going to ask her
any real questions or insist on an
answer but he kind of does here and
she's not willing to give it let's
listen
so is this
a bill to preserve access
as it is today with roe in place being
the law of the land or is is the goal of
the bill to expand it
the bottom line is this is a bill that
is going to enable the woman
to make the decision and so we can have
all kinds of arguments getting into the
weeds about this latter or the other
thing but the fact of the matter is that
the radical right-wing justices put on
the court by the republicans that
particularly the last three justices
have decided that they're just going to
overturn almost 50 years of a
constitutional right that is the bottom
line that we through this bill is
restoring that ability of women to make
the decision not government but senator
it's not getting into the weeds on this
thing or the other it's it's what the
legislation is it's what is guaranteed
by it uh as you may have heard in the
previous uh report and you probably know
uh from senator susan collins and lisa
murkowski
yeah it's uh just getting it senator
this bill that you're advocating for you
supported uh what does it do exactly i
don't want to get into the weeds
well it's that's so we're not going to
start talking about this and that and
it what's it's the bill that you support
what does it do exactly what is what's
the point of it
doesn't even want to tell you that
it doesn't even want to even even broad
strokes
now we know quite famously that um
politicians in dc are are often pushing
for legislation that they haven't read
that they don't want they don't want to
get into the specifics of it and all
that kind of stuff
but with this this is like just okay can
give us a couple sentences on what this
bill does
we don't even need to get into all the
specifics as much as that would be nice
also but give me a couple sentences like
what's the point of the legislation what
does it do doesn't he want to tell you
that
because what the legislation would do
and what she doesn't want to say
is that it would legalize abortion
nationwide through every stage of
pregnancy for any reason everywhere
so i could explain does you have to get
into weeds it doesn't take a long time
to explain you can explain it in one
sentence and that's what it does and she
doesn't want to admit that
and when you have one sided discussion
that
is always reluctant
to simply state
their case
and be honest about what they want
and then you've got the other side that
has no problem talking about what they
want
it's very eager to have the conversation
like that should tell you something
meanwhile um over at the bite
administration joe biden yesterday
had a couple of moments um that i think
we need to need to watch here he is i
think this is best without a lot of
context and there's always a bite it's
hard to give context to what he's saying
anyway but here he is
screaming about
i think food shortages it's not exactly
clear but he's very upset about
something
and uh let's listen to that
people
[Music]
the idea
uh what can you do but laugh it's not
even it's not funny i mean this guy he's
just wandering around the stage
screaming and no one knows what he's
talking about
what what are we talking about i mean
food shortages yeah those those
are happening but who are you yelling at
you're the president
the idea that people can't get food yeah
right you're in charge you're the guy
the mega crowd
the mega crowd is saying hey wouldn't it
be nice if we had enough formula to give
babies so they don't starve to death i
think that's what the mega crowds that's
and not just mega crowd it's just like
what everyone is saying every normal
people
think that it'd be nice if there was
enough food for babies in this country
that it is uh it is
words escape me to describe it's beyond
an outrage beyond uh an absurdity
that we live in in a in what's supposed
to be the greatest country in the world
and we're running out of food for our
babies
a totally avoidable situation
in fact i don't have the clip but there
was someone else in the administration
today
was was asked about this and he said
that well we've known about this we knew
about the problem and we were prepared
so you knew about it oh we knew about
this months ago knew back back in
february they say
what did you do about it
because i already gave an example of one
solution
it would have been pretty easy
especially if they knew that this
situation was approaching that it was
coming
which is to get the fda the hell out of
the way because that's all they do
that's all the fda does is they stand in
the way and they put red tape in in
place and regulations and all these
onerous things to make everything more
difficult and to constantly justify
their own jobs that's the only reason
most of these bureaucracies exist
they exist for their own sake they're
like self-perpetuating
they just exist to grow larger they're
cancerous tumors on our country are
these bureaucracies especially the fda
and when we get to a point where they're
actually needed like okay here's
something you guys could do here's a you
you do almost nothing all the time
except except
just try to justify your own existence
and your own paycheck you don't do
anything to help americans well here's a
situation where you could actually help
and they're nowhere to be found they're
giving cable news interviews and say oh
yeah we're on it we're working on it
they could have approved more of these
european
um
baby formula brands for sale america
because in europe they're not having
this problem
they got plenty of baby formula to go
around
and in other countries as well
so we start importing some of those
rather than making it illegal for people
to buy those kinds of formulas
oh no we can't
we can't allow you to feed your baby
until we at the fda have uh you know we
we have to approve each and every one we
have to take a look you need to give us
yeah your baby's hungry wants to eat but
uh we need
seven to eight months to really take a
look at this and run through all the
tests and do all this you know and
everything get everybody involved and
all the sign offs at every level and all
the paperwork
your baby can wait seven or eight months
to eat right
and then we have joe biden here's his
message
as we go into the midterms here's a
little message another great message of
hope from joe biden listen to this
this pandemic isn't over
today
we mark a tragic milestone here in the
united states one million covets
one million empty chairs around the
family dinner table
the pandemic isn't over so this is their
message as we head into the midterms
this is we have come a long way from
biden's boss at the time and who still
is his boss barack obama
getting elected on a message of hope and
change we've come a long way from that
we've come a long way from hope
now it's the pandemic isn't over
and
screaming about food shortages
my god um okay i want to play this for
you someone who goes by the handle queer
surgeon on tick-tock and who chops the
breasts off of minor girls for a living
is uh speaking out now in his own
defense and by the way he's quite proud
of what he does and is not embarrassed
or shamed at all
and um
here he is justifying himself
so i'm here to clarify and speak some
truths about what's happening with
gender affirming care and adolescence um
most of the bills that are going through
right now aim to limit this care for
people under the age of 18
and there's this false narrative that a
lot of teenagers are having gender
affirming surgery most of the teenagers
that are having surgery are getting
chest surgery and most of that is
happening before 18 because these
individuals didn't have access to early
enough medical treatment
so
using surgery as sort of this false
narrative to attack gender firming care
as a whole is not correct the truth is
that by limiting access to medical care
with some of these bills you're actually
going to cause more people to need
gender affirming surgical care
so the real headline there is that we've
got this guy the queer surgeon quote
unquote
admitting
that most of the uh the quote chest
surgeries which is uh which really is
mutilation they're just chopping the
breasts off of
physically healthy girls most of it is
happening to minor girls before the age
of 18.
and there's and he even admits there's a
lot of it happening
but tries to draw draw some sort of
distinction between
um
gender firm quote unquote gender
affirming surgery and this he said oh
there's this false narrative that
there's all kinds of the surgeries
happening to kids uh it's mostly just
the top surgeries
yeah that's that's you you're you're
chopping body parts off of children
a lot of them
this is currently happening
in the united states of america
14 year old girls are being brought in
and having their body parts removed
and
for all the talk of the backlash the
much-needed and deserved backlash
against this kind of thing i mean these
people are still they're not worried
they're out in public talking about it
and of course everything he says is just
completely the only honest thing we
heard there is that there's a lot of
this happening and it's mostly happening
to minor girls he's right about that
everything else is total nonsense
starting with the uh with the claim this
is medical care
this is not medical care
you know if you're chopping off a body
part
there are times when chopping off a body
part is medical care
there are times when limbs and parts of
the body have to be removed
double mastectomy because of uh for for
a cancer patient okay that's medical
care
somebody has their leg horribly mangled
and you have to take the leg off that's
medical care
but when you are removing
physically healthy body parts
from a physically healthy person that is
not medical care
that is mutilation by definition
and he also makes this claim that uh
this is only happening because
these girls are not given
uh the the medical care they need
earlier in life and if they got that
quote-unquote medical care then we
wouldn't have all these surgeries
total nonsense
not only because it's not actually
medical here that he's talking about but
also because like what is he referring
to what he's saying is that well these
girls
um who i guess he would say are boys
even though they have breasts that need
to be that he thinks need quote-unquote
to be chopped off
but if they were given uh like hormone
blockers and hormone pills and stuff
like that
then then we wouldn't be
and not enough of these kids are being
given the drugs early enough in life so
for him the solution is to drug more
kids and to drug them earlier in life
but he damn well knows that all the
drugs do
and all they're really meant to do is
put the kids on the path
to surgical mutilation
i mean the drugs are not going to stop a
girl from
growing breast permanently
in fact they're the ones who always say
that it's temporary puberty blockers are
temporary
that's what they always claim
and reversible the reversible part is
also not true that's a lie so there's
just so many every time these people
speak they speak for 45 seconds and
there are so many lies that you you it's
you know it's overwhelming it's it's
hard to even know where to begin in
sifting through all this
but
they themselves say it's a it's a
temporary thing okay so you're giving
the puberty blockers temporary even
though even from the temporary use of
the puberty blockers there's now going
to be lifelong effects
but then you take them off the people
blockers now what
well the next step is to put them in for
surgery
that's why this guy who
makes a lot of money chopping the
breasts off of girls that's why he wants
more girls
on the drugs and wants them on drugs
earlier because that creates the factory
conveyor belt
of girls who are going to eventually
make their way over to him
because most of the kids who are put on
these drugs they end up seeing they end
up they end up going the whole way
they're now in the system they're on the
drugs they're on the conveyor belt and
then
not all that far down the line you get
to the
butcher with the scalpel
and he's sitting there with his pockets
open waiting to uh you know make some
more money off of it
i also want this is kind of related um
in a way that might not be immediately
obvious but uh or maybe it is from the
daily wire report says a six-year-old
kentucky boy who ran in a cincinnati
marathon was visited by child protective
services his parents said this week
cammy and ben crawford whose son reneer
ran in the flying pig marathon in
cincinnati with his entire family was
was visited by cps at the family's home
in kentucky according to an instagram
post made by the family on monday
quote on friday social workers came to
our house and interviewed our children
because leaders in the running community
are calling running with children wrong
it then shows a picture of vernier
seated at a table outside the family's
home supposedly speaking with one of the
cps workers this needs to stop the
crawfords wrote the caption
our children are having emotional
breakdowns not from running but from a
mob that has been weaponized by
running's most accomplished and
celebrated individuals they're stating
that children running is abusive and not
providing any data or facts the reports
and stance are false hundreds of
witnesses including police officers and
hours of video footage corroborate when
will you apologize and retract
uh then it gives a little bit of context
here it says as controversy erupted
around the family olympic long distance
runner kara goucher seemingly condemned
the parents for allowing their son to
run in a 26.2 mile race
goucher wrote on may 4th
i don't know who needs to hear this but
a six-year-old cannot fathom what a
marathon will do to them physically
let's stop there for a second a
six-year-old cannot fathom
what a marathon will do to them
physically a six-year-old does not
understand what embracing misery is a
six-year-old who is struggling
physically does not realize they have
the right to stop and should
and there was someone that was so that
was one person i guess as well known in
the running community that's what we're
calling it i guess um who said this and
there were others who thought that it
was abusive to have the kid in the
marathon and then
reportedly apparently uh cps shows up to
check on the kid
okay now
as for putting your six-year-old in a
marathon
um
i would agree
that
that's not the right approach
like i would agree that that
six-year-olds are too young to be
running 26.2 miles even if they want to
and of course they're gonna want to i
mean any um
any boy when it comes to anything any
kind of physical exercise any anything
like that
if he sees you doing especially he sees
his dad doing he's gonna he's gonna want
to do it too so i
certainly believe that a six-year-old
would want to run a marathon
but yeah i i would say you're you're too
young at that age
and it's it's just it's too much
exercise
for for a kid that age you know the
potential damage to your muscles to your
bones
it's pretty high risk i mean really for
anyone to run in a marathon is a high
risk proposition physically
and you got to really know what you're
doing
and be highly prepared to undertake
something like that
but as the post pointed out six-year-old
can't really know what they're getting
themselves into or what the potential
long-term side effects could be i mean
how this could mess up your knees down
the line and all that kind of stuff
so i agree shouldn't have a kid in a
marathon
um does that mean that cps should be
showing up at your house about that
absolutely not
like there are there are kids who are
being subjected to real severe abuse in
this country who uh could use
a visit from cps
and having your kid take part in an
activity with you and exercise like that
doesn't fit the bill even if i think
it's not the right thing to do
um
and yet i can't help but
think
you know cps they're showing up at the
house because the six-year-old is not
old enough to run a marathon
and yet
we've got plenty of six-year-olds in
this country who are choosing their own
genders
cps not showing up for that
and even again go back to what uh this
goucher person said
six-year-old can't fathom what the
marathon will do to them physically
six-year-old doesn't understand what
they're doing
six-year-old doesn't realize they have
the right to stop
hmm
yeah sounds exactly like the situation
that six-year-olds are in when they're
put onto the path of gender transition
cannot fathom what that's going to do to
them physically young kids when they're
put on hormones cannot fathom what
that's going to do to them physically
don't understand what they're doing
and really importantly here they don't
realize that they have the right to stop
and that they should stop
just like goucher says of the kid in the
marathon
well it's a different kind of hellish
lifelong marathon that you're putting a
kid on when you put him in on this
gender transition path
and there are a whole lot of kids like
once they're in it and they're being
identified boy identifying as a girl and
they're on that path and they think that
uh they can't
that they're on the the conveyor belt
they think that they can't jump off they
think it's too late to jump off they're
going to disappoint people and they got
to just go with it
and you can listen to plenty of
de-transitioners who are now older and
adults and that's exactly what they'll
tell you
especially the ones who started when
they were kids
they were never comfortable with it they
never really understood what they were
doing and they never really felt like
they could stop
that's what's happening in america now
is uh if you
have your kid do too much exercise you
know then cps will show up but if you if
they were to instead of having the the
young boy in a marathon if they were to
dress him up like a girl and put him on
the path to drugs and um genital
mutilation no problem
if anything cps would show up knock on
the door and award them a ribbon a medal
forget about cps showing up you're gonna
have you know time magazine the today
show they're gonna be there wanting to
do a profile on your courage and on your
what a courageous brave family you are
completely upside down and uh backwards
as always let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
god says the ash-breasted tit tyrant is
a species of bird in the family
tyranna day it is found in bolivia and
peru its natural habitat is habitat is
subtropical or tropical
uh it is threatened by habitat loss well
thanks for ruining the joke scott
and i don't believe anyway that the ash
breasted tit turret is threatened by
extinction because like i said there's
gonna be a whole flocks of them tomorrow
in dc in dc for the women's march so i
just don't i don't buy it
rachel says it's true i thought my
friend was joking with me when he said
he got sent home from work because of a
turtle
so apparently if you find one desert
tortoise the entire construction site
must be shut down
so many stories like this that i've
heard a lot of them in the comments
section too um
you know we know people are getting
arrested for violating the endangered
species act but as i said yesterday
there's people in the construction
especially in certain regions of the
country uh people in the construction
business know all about this because
entire projects shut down
not even because the project might kill
an endangered species but just because
it may
inconvenience or irritate
or
qualify as harassment of an endangered
species
uh e4 32 says vote if you don't want to
see matt do any type of dance have
compassion and let him back out thank
you for that e432
look here's what here's the solution
here
i know i mentioned in in my fit of
insanity i mentioned that i would do the
interpretive dance
uh it when i when we get to a million
subscribers and i did say that and you
know that i would never back out of a
promise but
if you know i'm gonna give you
in the audience
and in the sweet baby gang i'm gonna
give you a chance
to think about this and if you decide
that you don't want me to do this then i
will respect your wishes so it's not me
pulling out okay it's not me backing out
of a promise but if you decide that you
want to have compassion
and be good people and tell me never
mind you don't have to do this then i
will let
i will give you an opportunity to tell
me that
and i'll respect your wishes in that
case so just just decide
do you want to be good decent people and
say never mind matt don't do the
interpretive dance or do you want to be
horrible people and force me into it
it's up to you
it's totally up to you
um
let's see
ross says two observations when i flew
for the marines in san diego we were
forbidden to land in large areas of one
of the gigantic bases due to the
endangered fairy shrimp
not joking
and two the bald eagle is a symbol of
our freedom so that dude got jailed for
killing one but countless people go un
punished for burning the literal symbol
of our freedom the american flag makes
total sense that's a really good point
also
um
that the whole reason
and you could say well a bald eagle is a
living thing and a flag isn't yeah but a
bald eagle is it's a bird
and it's perfectly there are all kinds
of birds that you're allowed to kill
perfectly legal
um but when you're not allowed to kill
the bald eagle even though it's not
endangered and the only reason is
because of its symbolic significance
well
if we're protecting things because of
their symbolic significance then why
would that not extend to the flag which
is the actual symbol of our country very
good question
jake says matt i appreciate your take on
the baby formula shortage and agree that
it's a big problem but i feel you're
missing an opportunity to advocate for
breastfeeding and make clear that it's
the best thing for mom slash baby
the switch to formula has been part and
parcel with the feminist takeover of the
family
uh i just don't
agree with you
i don't think that
formula has anything to do with feminism
at all first of all
i think formula is a wonderful thing
it's that there are babies who are alive
today and would not be because of
formula
there are babies as we said
in the past who would have starved to
death or been victims of malnutrition
because they weren't able to breastfeed
for for any variety of reasons
and uh but you know now that we have
formulas so we don't that's if the
formula is available on the shelves you
don't have to worry about that
so i don't agree with you there and i
don't think that the breastfeeding
versus formula decision is some kind of
you know morally loaded super important
situation
i think it's it's hard enough to be a
parent
and i want to be an advocate
for becoming a parent and starting a
family like we talked about at the
beginning of the show i think it's a
wonderful thing
um
but you just make it harder on people in
unnecessary ways
it's difficult enough to be a parent
modern society
introduces enough additional challenges
but then on top of that you just like
every little choice you make as a parent
gets picked apart
and you know debated and you know
anything at all like people parents know
this if you you can think you might want
to share something about your family or
about something that you did online just
because you think it's a nice fun thing
and so you say oh this is what we did
today and people will just start picking
it apart
you'll have the mom brigade come in and
the the dad brigade and they're going to
be picking it apart oh you shouldn't be
doing that and that's a bad choice this
would be better as a parent
so every little decision you make as a
parent becomes this
hotly debated controversial thing and i
just think that a lot of that is
unnecessary
i mean there are really important
decisions you'll make as a parent uh
there are morally loaded decisions that
you'll make as a parent i don't think
breastfeeding versus formula is one of
them here would be my recommendation
and i think this this applies to a lot
of parenting situations not all of them
but many of them
figure out what works for you
and your family
and j and do that
and and the baby honestly is going to be
fine either way
and as long as you're caring for them
and loving the child
when it comes to feeding the child make
sure they get you know as long as they
get the right nutrients that they need
figure out what works for you what
you're able to do and just do that
really simple that's that's my advice
it's the most infamous supreme court
case in memory and the deadliest
decision in history but even 50 years
after roe v wade few know the truth
behind the landmark decision a decision
that's enabled the destruction of over
64 million babies since 1971. well the
daily wire has taken a wrecking ball to
the 40 rather the four big lies the
abortion history was built upon with our
original documentary choosing death the
legacy of roe and there are there are
probably 40 lies or a lot more but the
four big ones are uncovered in this uh
documentary and especially we get into
the history of where how this came to
pass and uh why it needs to pass away
finally you hear the facts and stories
the abortion regime has suppressed for
generations and get a clear-eyed view at
the brutal reality they desperately
don't want you to see some of this
content is hard to take in but a few
subjects if any are more important than
this
you'll see what i mean when you watch
the trailer here it is
many times when we
did this
as we started
patients would
begin crying and
protesting
but once we had begun dilating the
cervix and passing instruments into the
uterus it was too late to stop
[Music]
i was handing hush money
to
women who we had left pieces of their
baby
we had put these women's lives in
jeopardy we'd put their lives at risk
and we were literally giving them a
check for 800
and for a poor woman 800 is a lot of
money
i mean there have been so many moments
in the last decade plus of going
undercover in abortion clinics myself
and seeing
just heartbreaking things women vomiting
in the hallway of an abortion clinic
crying out in pain the late term
abortionist talking casually
about how they would literally leave a
born-alive baby to die or if you deliver
the baby in the toilet then you pick it
up and stuff it in a plastic bag and
bring it to us
babies are being born alive
and the backs of their necks are being
slit
they are being drowned
um their necks are being snapped
it's it's happening more often than
people want to think about
these abortion facilities these abortion
providers these doctors
they don't care about these women
and you're just you're realizing it
you're watching in front of your own
eyes play out america's greatest horror
story
which is
how we butcher children
in the name of choice
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so please help us expose the truth tell
your friends to watch and if you're not
already become a daily wire member and
tune in today to watch our documentary
on abortion you don't want to miss it
choosing death the legacy of roe go to
dailywire.com choosing and join the
fight today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel kelly karan who is a
popular personality on the platform
twitch where people usually go to watch
other people play video games but
apparently some twitch streamers will um
simply go about their mundane everyday
lives and broadcast all of it and fans
will sit and watch it's a bit like the
truman show except in this case the
stars of the show are aware that they're
on camera and also a lot of time they
have none of the charm or personality of
jim carrey's character in that film and
that brings us to streamer kelly who was
live streaming
while cooking a few days ago
and there's nothing immediately strange
about watching somebody cook i've been
known to enjoy a cooking show or two in
my time but usually you watch somebody
cook because they're a master chef and
you're watching in order to learn their
techniques
or else they're an amateur chef and
you're watching to see gordon ramsay
verbally abuse them for overcooking the
salmon or whatever
what i don't quite understand is
watching someone cook alone in their
kitchen
when they apparently aren't even
familiar with the rudimentary basics of
cooking
now i'm speaking somewhat rhetorically
here i do actually understand why people
sit and watch live streams where the
star of the show has nothing interesting
to say and isn't doing anything worth
watching it's the same thing that drives
the screen addiction that most people in
this country suffer from which is
loneliness despair
lack of meaning in life people turn to
the internet for companionship having
given up on real physical relationships
and on physical existence in general
but that's a topic for another time the
point today is this particular twitch
streamer kelly karan who um
was broadcasting live while cooking
attempting to cook rather a steak
and then things went sideways in a hurry
let's just watch this as this unfolds
here
so she's got the it's it's smoking all
over the place she's got the steak
probably way overcooked
she doesn't turn the burner off
now there's the fire
whipping the pan around the room spread
the fire everywhere
i don't know what to do guys i don't
know what to do turn the stove off first
of all turn the stove off the stove's
still on help
help help help
now she's just shouting at them
out the door
turn the stove off first thing you do
yeah that's frustrating
especially as a dad you know
that that's that's tough to watch
okay
so she almost burned down her house as
it happens
apparently the fire department showed up
in time and that she escaped without any
major property damage or personal injury
thank god but it could have been much
worse seeing as how she did literally
everything wrong as soon as the
overheated pan she was using to vaporize
that poor steak erupted into flames so
let's go through the missteps one by one
okay i think this will be very helpful
in fact i might save some lives right
here today and i will show so first she
blows on the flame
which of course only makes the problem
worse
it's like when you're starting a
campfire and you want to get it going
and you've got the the embers and so you
start blowing on it because you want to
make the fire get bigger
that's why you don't do that with a
kitchen fire
blowing only puts out a fire when the
fire is contained on the wick of a
birthday candle
if the flame is much bigger than that
you fuel the fire by giving it more air
so
then she whips the pan around which by
the way is giving it more air okay
because she's whipping it around and she
puts it in her sink where she attempts
and thankfully fails to pour water on it
because if she had succeeded in dousing
her grease fire with water
she would have caused a massive fireball
to erupt out of her sink and likely set
her cabinets aflame
and also probably her hair and
everything else
and then she whips the pan back around
spraying hot flaming oil all over the
kitchen like some kind of fiery
sprinkler and sets it back on the stove
without turning the burner off
then she leaves the flame
and the the stove that's still on and
just starts randomly shouting help out
her front door
it's a master class in what not to do
when you have a grease fire in your
kitchen so here's what you should do for
the record
first
remove the pan from its heat source okay
that's the first thing you do
turn off the heat source
your next step is to smother the flame
don't blow on it don't dump water on it
don't dump gasoline or lighter fluid
smother it if the fire small enough you
could probably take care of the problem
by just putting the lid on the pan which
originally she probably could have done
that before she blew on it she probably
just put the lid on it and that would
have been good enough
it's a bigger fire than you'll need to
smother it by dumping either baking soda
or salt on it just make sure it's baking
soda not baking powder or else you'll be
in for an unfortunate surprise
um if you don't have either of those
things handy or if the fire's already
too large to contain that way then use
your fire extinguisher and if you don't
have a fire extinguisher then hopefully
you have a fire blanket if you don't
have a fire blanket and you can't
smother with a lid and you don't have
baking soda or salt or the fire's too
big by this point to put it out that way
then just toss yourself into the fire as
penance for being so woefully unprepared
now actually your last resort in that
situation is to get out of the house and
call 9-1-1
so you didn't think you'd get fire
safety tips on the matt well show today
but that's where the conversation took
us
and all this leads me to a deeper point
that i think needs to be made here
the comedy of errors that we just
witnessed is a very small microcosm of a
much bigger problem
afflicting our society a huge number of
americans do not possess even the most
basic life skills
like how to put out a kitchen fire
how to cook in the first place so that
you hopefully you don't have fires
um food safety
first aid housekeeping money management
budgeting how to do your taxes how to
change a tire car repair home repair the
list goes on
all of us are deficient and almost all
of us are deficient in some of those
areas many of us are deficient in all of
them
and the reason in large part is that
these sorts of things are not being
taught in schools anymore
now obviously parents should be training
their children in these skills
but 50 million kids in this country
spend most of their waking hours through
most of their formative years in school
buildings and that would be in theory
the perfect place to impart a lot of
this kind of knowledge
and there was a time when lots of these
things were covered in school
they even had a whole subject home
economics it was called and they were
that subject was devoted to everyday
life skills like these
but those courses started falling by the
wayside in part because it was
considered too retrograde and unfeminist
to teach kids especially girls how to
cook and clean
and also in part because public school
curriculum started to revolve more and
more around standardized testing and
college readiness
like the focus now is to make kids ready
for college
not for life
and in part because the schools needed
to make room in the day to teach about
lgbt pride and crt and other forms of
insidious nonsense
the end result is that kids whittle away
hundreds of hours in these alleged
educational facilities and come away
from it with almost no practical or
useful knowledge or skills at all
next you know they're live streaming
while burning down their kitchen
you teach these skills
in school
and again would be great if parents
taught it
but it's also a self-perpetuating
problem because the parents we have a
whole generation of parents who don't
know these skills either because they
didn't learn them
teach the skills in in in school isn't
that an interesting concept
to actually
give
kids
useful knowledge that will make their
lives better and easier
make them more self-sufficient
who would have thought
and that's why on second thought maybe
i'm not going to cancel kelly karan
instead i think it's our utterly useless
education system that must be once again
today
cancelled
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great weekend talk to you on monday
godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audios mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2022. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin